et pour en parler nous sommes avec
laurent bortolussi journalistes de
lagence indépendante line presse bonjour
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
franc joué alors cet article 24 toujours
au coeur de la polémique il va donc
faire l'objet d'une réécriture
est-ce que c'est du bon sens selon vous
et qu'est ce qu'il faut modifier aussi
écouter nous ne sommes pas favorables à
une réécriture de ce texte de loi nous
pensons depuis le début que cette loi
est inutile qu'elle est dangereuse pour
la liberté de la presse qu'elle est
dangereuse pour tous les journalistes
les journalistes rappellent dans les
semaines stream également des
journalistes indépendants qui
travaillent sur la voie publique
j'avais mis le doigt sur le flux de
cette loi depuis le début c'est à dire
qu'elle permettait à apporter le
procureur de la république d'ouvrir et
de rentrer en phase de poursuite sur
n'importe qui à partir du moment où un
journaliste faisait des images qui
gênait qui gênait l'autorité qui gênait
qui gênait l'état vendre la peau de
l'ours avant de l'avoir tué nous verrons
ce qu'il y a dans cette nouvelle mouture
on a quand même beaucoup de doutes à
cette loi ne sert à rien j'ai pu en
discuter avec des policiers notamment
samedi dernier lors de la manifestation
à paris des policiers eux-mêmes n'y sont
pas favorables
tu crois qu'il serait de bon ton et de
bourges ans de supprimer tout simplement
de cette polémique
vous vous croyez pas que c'est justement
un pas vers la suppression d'un de ce
texte le gouvernement qui est en
mauvaise posture gérald darmanin
également donc peut-être que pour faire
passer un peu la pilule finalement il ya
cette volonté de dire on va réécrire la
taxe on va représenter une cotisent pour
envoyer un peu le poisson alors ce
serait de bon ton
maintenant il serait peut-être un
message intéressant que les autorités
disent monde a écouté ce texte de loi
étaient mal formulées mal compris on
supprime tout simplement si je temporise
et quelques quelques jours quelques
semaines ou d'après ce que j'ai compris
quelques mois parce que ça va être long
à faire qu'ils le fassent mais nos
journalistes nous sommes toujours sur la
même ligne nous voulons la suppression
de ce texte de loi qui est je le
rappelle dangereux dangereux pour notre
travail dangereux pour la liberté de la
presse
je vois mal ce qui peut être écrit ce
qui peut être refait roule on verra bien
rare de toute façon mais nous restons
effectivement que je voulais dire sur
les mêmes une suppression totale de
cette procédure de mise en cause des
journalistes sur des images qu'il faut
soit avoir sur les auditions d'hier
notamment saladin gérald darmanin donc
qui a réitéré son soutien au préfet de
police didier lallement
qu'en pensez vous et puis surtout qu
attendez-vous la de la sortie d'
emmanuel macron qui doit s'exprimer dans
le média brut
j'ai dit bah on y attend on en attend
pas grand chose si vous voulez c'est un
peu la technique habituelle que l'on
connaît depuis quelques années on essaie
de noyer le patient de poisson par dont
on fait la communication au nord tout ça
on dit d'un côté nous avons compris les
problématiques mais l'autre côté on fait
tout à fait autre chose que vous
rappelle et comme j'ai pu le dire
notamment sur notre antenne que gérald
darmanin aaa dit publiquement pendant
des jours et des jours que la liberté de
la presse était quelque chose qui était
absolument indispensable qui ne tenait
fermement et de l'autre côté sur le
terrain nos journalistes de terrain
nous avons constaté que les forces de
l'ordre avaient des ordres tout à fait
contraire à ce que disait monsieur
darmana c'est à dire que les
journalistes depuis quelques jours sont
d'assez sont empêchés de travailler donc
une dichotomie entre ce qui est affiché
publiquement est ce qui se passe
réellement sur le terrain
donc on est on est quand même
extrêmement peu dont je disais sur les
propos de de gérald darmanin
concernant didier à l'allemand oui moi
il me semble difficile que didier
lallement puisse rester à son poste
après le passif qu'il a dit là à paris
on a vu notamment la différence de
gestion du maintien de l'ordre
entre par exemple monsieur collomb qui
étaient là au début de la présidence d'
emmanuel macron avec un autre préfet
nous avons eu monsieur castanet avec
monsieur l'allemand est maintenant
monsieur d'armagnac nationalement les
choses ne se passent pas très très bien
depuis qu'ils sont là je crois que
président de la république devrait en
tirer les conséquences
il ya un moment dans l'histoire et dans
la vie la république qu'il faut savoir
changer les hommes
quand sur le terrain cela ne fonctionne
plus du tout et c'est le cas aujourd'hui
et toute cette polémique concernant
justement bon l'article le 24 qu'est ce
que cela révèle sur le rapport que peut
avoir l'exécutif le gouvernement avec
les médias en france aujourd'hui
moi je crois que cela révèle quelque
chose qui est plus profond
une relation entre les médias et
l'exécutif moi j'ai que j'explique
depuis le début que cette loi n'est pas
faite pour ce qu'elle est qu'elle est
censée défendre cette loi n'est pas
faite en tout cas l'article 24 dans sa
première mouture n'était pas fait pour
défendre des policiers ce n'est pas vrai
c'est ce que le gouvernement met en
avant cette loi était tout simplement un
outil juridique qui permettait face à
une situation qui va devenir très
difficile dans les mois qui viennent à
moi qui le dit les services de
renseignement on va avoir une crise
sociale extrême dans les mois qui
viennent avec cette sortie que vides
avec des millions de chômeurs en plus
avec des entreprises qui vont
massivement licencié il doit y avoir une
répercussion sur le terrain sur la voie
publique
on va sans doute avoir des
manifestations très importantes sans
doute aussi très violente l'état grâce à
ce type cap ne voulait pas du tout du
tout du tout protéger les policiers
l'image des policiers il voulait se
doter d'un outil qui permet tait qui
permettait à la justice aux procureurs
de dire à un moment on va mettre en
cause les journalistes les journalistes
indépendants les journalistes sur le
terrain pour leur
gérance on s'évite de publier sur les
réseaux sociaux des images de ces
manifestations et de ces contestations
c'est juste un outil technique il faut
il faut bien avoir conscience de ce que
de ce qu'ils étaient certains articles
c'était un outil qui je le répète
permettait à l'état de faire en sorte
d'éviter que les gens qui se trouvent à
bourges de clermont ferrand toulouse je
vois ce qui se passe à paris quand lyon
ou marseille
c'est ça le sens l'essence même de cet
article 24
il faut pas être dupe sur ce que sur ce
qu'il peut oublier de faire les derniers
événements usage de la force contre
hausse
ce producteur par exemple ça a un impact
au sein de l'opinion publique on sait
que manama qu'on va certainement en
parler longuement jeudi
est ce que ça a changé la donne vous
pensez concernant justement cet article
oui bien évidemment
et malgré ce qui est arrivé à ce
producteur de musique je serais tenté de
dire que cette affaire est tombée à
point nommé et malheureusement pour le
budget de l'intérieur parce qu'il a
révélé toute l'utilité de l'image
beaucoup l'ont dit mais c'est vrai si
cette si ces images n'étaient pas sortis
aujourd'hui ce producteur michel est
claire serait en prison parce qu'il
aurait eu du mal face à toute cette
masse de policiers qui sont en plus
assermentés d'arriver à prouver sa bonne
foi depuis qu'il a commis aucun geste de
violence face aux policiers
donc l'image n'est pas un ennemi en
démocratie faut bien comprendre il faut
bien l'intégrer l'état français comme
beaucoup d'états a du mal à n'a jamais
réussi à intégrer le fait qu'il y ait
autant de l'image avec cet événement
depuis 10 ans 15 ans des toutous ses
téléphones portables de tous et direct
qui sont faits lors notamment d'aider
d'événements publics et c'est quelque
chose qu'ils n'arriveront pas qu'ils
n'arriveront pas fait reculer alors il
essaie maladroitement avec une loi de se
dire on va pouvoir interdire aux
journalistes indépendants tournée on va
essayer d'empêcher les eaux sociaux de
montrer ce qui se passe mais on est dans
une autre époque on est plus en 1990 on
est plus en 2000 voire même en 2010 on
est dans une nouvelle époque et je crois
qu'il serait bon que ces politiques
comprennent
on sait comment s'en inspirer merci
beaucoup à vous laurent bordeaux aussi
d'avoir répondu en direct à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste de l'agencé indépendante
line presse